[Música]
son las ocho y treinta y uno de la noche
en Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos en
directo América edición nocturna ustedes
Les agradecemos su sintonía vamos con
los titulares de esta jornada
ocho millones de personas siguen bajo
alerta climática en el estado
estadounidense de California que
continúa enfrentando el llamado río
atmosférico un fenómeno que ha causado
al menos 19 muertes y ha generado
Fuertes lluvias e inundaciones desde
diciembre pasado
al menos 96 puntos de Vidas nacionales
se encuentran bloqueados en Perú lo que
ya hace sentir la escasez de alimentos
en regiones como puno los manifestantes
siguen pidiendo la renuncia de la
presidenta Dina boluarte el cierre del
Congreso y el adelanto de elecciones
ampliamos desde Perú
el presidente ucraniano vuelo dimirceles
que aseguró que el ataque contra el
edificio Residencial de dni Pro
demuestra que se necesita una entrega de
armas más veloz a las tropas de kiev
Naciones Unidas pidió investigar el
bombardeo que deja al menos 40
fallecidos como un crimen de guerra
[Música]
damos inicio en Estados Unidos Porque
después de meses de sequía el estado de
California hace frente a un fenómeno
conocido como río atmosférico que ha
provocado torrenciales lluvias en la
zona lo que ha causado inundaciones y un
sinnúmero de daños materiales de acuerdo
con los reportes al menos 19 personas
han perdido la vida debido a las
precipitaciones Y al menos ocho millones
de ciudadanos permanecen en alerta Pese
a que se espera que las condiciones
mejoren en los próximos días
California se mantiene en alerta máxima
millones de personas han sido afectadas
por las lluvias torrenciales vientos
feroces y fuertes inundaciones que
afectan al Estado desde Navidad por un
fenómeno conocido como río atmosférico
es decir una franja de humedad que
transporta grandes cantidades de agua de
los trópicos
estamos viendo que este tipo de cosas
ocurren con más frecuencia ahora con el
crecimiento de los incendios y el
aumento de las temperaturas del océano
tenemos mucha más humedad en el aire
después de los incendios que fueron
severos aunque los pronósticos indican
que las condiciones mejorarán al
finalizar la semana alrededor de 8
millones de personas permanecen bajo
alerta de inundación en todo el estado
según el servicio geológico de
California se han sufrido más de 400
deslizamientos de Tierra desde el 30 de
diciembre y los vientos violentos han
derribado miles de árboles además de
causar constantes cortes de energía
provocar daños a residencias y dejar
ciudades enteras bajo el agua
recientemente el Gobierno Federal hizo
una declaración de emergencia y prometió
ayudas a los californianos
el presidente Joe biden declaró que
existe un gran desastre en el estado de
California y ordenó ayuda Federal para
complementar los esfuerzos de
recuperación estatales y locales este
fenómeno no había sido visto en
California en décadas un estado que
normalmente es afectado por fuertes
sequías e incendios forestales
característicos de su clima seco
Hablamos ahora de América Latina al
menos nueve regiones de Perú se han
visto afectadas por una nueva jornada de
huelga nacional en la que se presentaron
más de 90 bloqueos la población de
ayaviri en la provincia peruana de
Melgar Se declaró en paro indefinido
contra el gobierno tras la destitución
del expresidente Pedro Castillo
Francisco Zacarías corresponsal de Franz
24 se desplazó hasta el sitio y conversó
con los indígenas que lideran el paro
ayaviri provincia de Melgar es un pueblo
indígena que se encuentra en la ruta al
cusco ellos son peruanos de condición
humilde que se dedican a la agricultura
su principal fuente de ingreso que
afirman está dañada por la sequía y por
el abandono de gobierno ayaviri se ha
declarado En paro indefinido nosotros
nos en verdaderamente pensábamos que una
presidenta podría Apo
derarnos una mujer pero lamentable hemos
sido traiciones de todas las mujeres de
Perú entero todavía nos dicen que ella
es una provinciana pero lamentablemente
nos están matando a nuestros hijos
inocentes nos han o sea nos han dirigido
con armas mientras el pueblo solamente
teníamos un trapo y agua para
defendernos nosotros no teníamos en la
mano nada lo que más indigna los pueblos
indígenas es que el gobierno la clase
política y los medios locales
desprestigia su protesta llamando los
terroristas ellos rechazan la acusación
enérgicamente Nunca es su terrorista nos
conocemos No hay ninguna ningún
terrorista tampoco hay infiltrados
bolivianos no hay ponches rojos
solamente Nosotros
con nuestros palos con las ondas que
tenemos no no que no nos ataquen de que
ha llegado armamento de del país
boliviano mientras mucho de sus
compañeros viajan a Lima para protestar
en la denominada marcha de los cuatro
suyos en hayavivir y afirman que se
mantendrán en lucha hasta que se
produzcan los cambios que ellos esperan
en otras noticias Colombia sigue siendo
el principal productor mundial de hoja
de Coca la materia primordial para la
producción de cocaína de acuerdo con la
ONU los cultivos ilícitos pasaron de
143.000 hectáreas a 204 mil hectáreas
para el año 2021 lo que representa un
incremento del 43%, una cifra récord el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro ha
reiterado el fracaso de la política
antidrogas y de la prohibición que
impulsaron gobiernos anteriores
limítrofe con Venezuela el catatumbo
alberga la mayor superficie de cultivo
ilegal de coca en el mundo José del
Carmen abril es uno de los cientos de
miles de personas que abandonaron la
agricultura tradicional para cultivar
estas hojas verdes en la coca para los
campesinos desde el 86 para acá se
convirtió en el gobierno que nunca ha
venido por acá y ustedes preguntarán por
qué o el gobierno pregunta por qué Por
qué la coca es con la que se ha llevado
a hacer escuelas hacer puestos de salud
carreteras hacer la vivienda en el país
que más produce la pasta que sirve para
el polvo blanco que consumen en Estados
Unidos y Europa los recolectores son El
eslabón más débil de la cadena el
presidente izquierdista Gustavo Petro
dijo querer cambiar la política
antidrogas a nivel nacional e
internacional pero los campesinos
cocaleros piden todavía más apoyo para
la transición a otras economías y menos
criminalización varias oportunidades por
ser recolector de Coca nos nos tildan de
de guerrilleros de narcotraficantes de
bueno de ser un delincuente aquí en
Colombia mi gobierno nos persigue muchas
veces nos han llevado presos en
diciembre el gobierno se comprometió a
dejar de perseguir a los campesinos con
menos de dos hectáreas de coca y la
semana pasada la Policía Nacional fijo
su meta de erradicación de cultivos
ilícitos para 2023 en 20 mil hectáreas
una reducción de 60% con respecto al
objetivo para 2022 las autoridades
buscarán este año atacar los eslabones
más lucrativos del negocio y luchar
contra la violencia recrudecida por Las
Guerras entre grupos armados y
narcotraficantes
seguimos con temas de política
antidrogas Este martes inicia en Estados
Unidos El sonado y esperado juicio
contra Genaro García Luna máximo
responsable de la seguridad pública
durante el gobierno de Felipe Calderón
en México el exfuncionario está acusado
de narcotráfico y de aceptar sobornos
del Cartel De Sinaloa a cambio de
facilitar la operación del grupo han
pasado más de tres años de su captura y
la pena mínima es de 10 años que podría
llegar hasta la cadena perpetua para
analizar esta información conectamos con
pennyley Ramírez ella es periodista y
escritora bienvenida France 24
puntualmente Cuál es la acusación contra
García Luna qué es lo que permitía el
entonces alto funcionario y quien
denunció que recibía recibía sobornos
bueno la actuación plantea que
tuvo durante muchos años trabajando al
mismo tiempo para el gobierno de México
un altísimo funcionario como el civil de
más alto Rango encargados de temas de
seguridad y con el el cartel de Sinaloa
específicamente ayudando principalmente
a Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán y a la vez el
recibía información y recibía dinero de
Estados Unidos a través de los programas
de ayuda bilateral para combatir
justamente que las drogas llegaran a
Estados Unidos es decir se le acusa de
ser una especie de triple agentes una
investigación que comenzó en Estados
Unidos se votó ante un gran Jurado en
Estados Unidos y actualmente está
esperando el juicio este juicio que
comienza justamente mañana aquí en Nueva
York y es hasta ahora el juicio más
importante que ha derivado de el juicio
contra Joaquín Guzmán El Líder del
Cartel De Sinaloa que ocurrió también en
Nueva York entre 2018 y principios de
2019 Bueno usted ya lo estaba
mencionando García Luna trabajaba para
el gobierno mexicano y tenía vínculos
con la DEA pero al mismo tiempo con el
cartel de Sinaloa cómo pudo ocurrir esto
durante tanto tiempo bueno ocurrió
durante más de una década y parte de eso
es de lo que queremos descubrir en el en
el juicio a ver básicamente lo que el
juicio va a permitir es también hacernos
una pregunta muy importante acerca de
cómo Estados Unidos Elige a sus aliados
en la región en América Latina no es la
primera vez que una persona en quien el
gobierno de Estados Unidos ha confiado
termina siendo cuestionado o investigado
por corrupción Y también vamos a poder
saber más acerca de cómo existían estas
colaboraciones y un poco porque hay un
fracaso que se ve en los números de la
guerra contra el narcos y la misma
persona que estaba encargada de evitar
que las drogas llegaran a Estados Unidos
era si según esta acusación la misma
persona que al mismo tiempo estaba
ayudando al cartel de Sinaloa bueno
Felipe Calderón fue presidente entre
2006 y 2012 la captura de García Luna se
produce en 2019 porque tardó tanto
tiempo Bueno eso es otra pregunta
importante no solamente que los años
sino que además García Luna después de
dejar su puesto en México en 2012 se
mudó a Miami él vivió en Miami en una
una casa de más de tres millones de
dólares y y parte de todo eso es lo que
explicamos en un podcast que acabamos de
hacer acá en Nueva York que se llama
versus García Luna que es justamente
desgranando este juicio pero básicamente
se le investigó durante mucho tiempo
pero durante mucho tiempo no se hizo
nada Ahora vamos a aprender en el juicio
exactamente En qué consistía su
colaboración y esperemos también
entender Por qué no se le juzgó desde
antes anilea a ustedes Muchas gracias
por su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en France 24
gracias continuamos con información de
la guerra en Ucrania porque el
presidente
aseguró que el ataque contra el edificio
Residencial en dinipro deja en evidencia
que se requiere una entrega más veloz de
armas a las tropas de kiev esto el mismo
día en que Naciones Unidas pidió que el
bombardeo se investigue como un crimen
de guerra Al haber tenido como objetivo
una estructura civil al menos 40
personas perdieron la vida al tiempo que
otras treinta continúan desaparecidos y
con el pasar de las horas disminuyen las
esperanzas de encontrar sobrevivientes
el servicio de seguridad de Ucrania ya
ha comenzado a recopilar información
sobre el ejército ruso que preparó y
llevó a cabo este ataque
sin duda todas las personas culpables de
este crimen de guerra serán
identificadas y responsabilizadas David
Pro hace como otros similares ataques
cae en particular bajo la jurisdicción
de la Corte Penal Internacional y muy
muy correcto y utilizaremos todas las
oportunidades disponibles tanto
nacionales como internacionales para
garantizar que todos los asesinos rusos
todos los que dan y Ejecutan órdenes de
terror con misiles contra nuestro pueblo
enfrente en penas legales y para que
cumplan su pena
en China se acerca la celebración del
año nuevo lunar el domingo 22 de enero
una época festiva en la que millones de
personas retornan a sus hogares esta vez
se da en medio de un aumento pronunciado
de contagios de covid-19 desde que el
gobierno de Shin Pink eliminó su
política de cero covid el informe es de
Manuela Cano
volver a casa en medio de un ambiente
enrarecido miles de personas dejaron
atrás Shanghai para celebrar el año
nuevo lunar en sus lugares de origen un
retorno que se da en medio de un
pronunciado aumento de contagios por
Kobe 19 y que podría haberse afectado
por los desplazamientos masivos por todo
el territorio chino
no estoy preocupado por el virus porque
nuestra inmunidad está bien porque somos
jóvenes no me ha dado positivo desde la
reapertura china se enfrenta a una
oleada de contagios desde que el
gobierno eliminó de manera repentina una
muy estricta política de cero covid que
se mantuvo vigente desde el inicio de la
pandemia y que derivó a finales del año
pasado en un hartazgo ciudadano que se
tradujo en manifestaciones sin
precedentes contra el gobierno de
Aunque la eliminación de las
restricciones Ha generado preocupación
alrededor del mundo esta ha sido un
alivio para muchos estoy muy feliz
debido a la pandemia estuvimos
encerrados durante tres años lo que fue
particularmente largo finalmente se
levantaron los bloqueos ahora es mucho
más fácil volver a casa la Organización
Mundial de la Salud ha sido reiterativa
al demandarle al país cifras verídicas y
transparentes sobre el número de casos y
de muertes unos pedidos que según las
autoridades chinas han sido cumplidos a
cabalidad
en el breve periodo de poco más de un
mes el china ha realizado cinco
intercambios técnicos y un diálogo con
la Organización Mundial de la Salud las
contribuciones positivas que china ha
hecho a la lucha mundial contra la
pandemia de covid-19 han sido
ampliamente reconocidas por la OMS y la
comunidad internacional
el sábado se conoció que desde inicios
de diciembre 60.000 personas han muerto
por causas relacionadas al coi 19 en el
país asiático hasta la revelación de
esos datos china solo reconocía poco más
de 5000 muertes por la enfermedad así
llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros que ya llega a más con toda la
información del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]